so one of the the most interesting
things that I found and that was most
surprising to me really was in my
interviews with egg donors and sperm
donors it became very clear that the
sperm donors had a very straightforward
view of themselves as fathers to the
children who are born as a result of
their donations whereas the women were
absolutely adamant that they were not
mothers and that's so surprising because
women and men each provide half of the
genetic material that you need to create
an embryo and so the question is well
why would they have such different ways
of thinking about their relationship to
their biological offspring and I think
that it really comes back to in our
society how we define what makes a
mother and what makes a father and as a
result of reproductive technologies the
definition of what makes a mother is
much more flexible there are different
women who can contribute to one
particular child so there can be one
woman who provides the egg one woman who
carries the pregnancy another woman or
women who raise the child
and so in that sense our definitions of
motherhood can be sort of partitioned
out into different elements whereas our
definitions of fatherhood are not quite
so flexible we still have a cultural
equation in which providing a sperm
makes a man a father and so it's it's
very difficult for sperm donors to say
something that I heard from egg donors
over and over sperm donors would not say
well all I did was give just the sperm
so I'm not the father
whereas egg donors were just you know to
a person I interviewed women in
different parts of the country who
donated through different donation
programs and I heard over and over and
over while all I did was all I gave was
just an egg and they can say just an egg
and I'm not the mother because they
weren't carrying the pregnancy they
weren't giving birth they weren't
raising the child so they were
distancing themselves from that label of
mother in part because of how technology
has changed how we define families
I didn't do research on surrogate
mothers or women who were the recipients
of egg donations for example or women
who are mothers through old-fashioned
means of reproduction but research by
other scholars really demonstrates that
the flexibility of these definitions so
if we took you know I was talking about
egg donor saying well it's just the egg
I didn't carry the pregnancy I didn't
give birth I didn't raise the child
people who interview surrogate mothers
find that surrogate mothers will say
well all I did was just the pregnancy I
didn't give the egg I'm not raising the
child and so surrogate mothers will
distance themselves from that label of
mother and so that's where I'm pointing
to the flexibility in our definitions of
maternity of what it is that makes a
woman a mother that the person who
provides the egg the person who provides
the pregnancy the person who raises the
child any one of those women could lay
claim to that label of mother or not
depending on her eventual intentions of
parenting that child
where we have seen some of the most
controversial court cases in assisted
reproduction have been of surrogacy so
there was the baby M trial in 1987 there
was another legal decision in California
Johnson V Calvert that came a few years
later and both of those were around the
death of who should be identified as a
parent I mean in the United States right
now in general the fertility industry
and assisted reproduction it goes pretty
much unregulated and so we have a
state-by-state system where some states
ban surrogacy some states allow
surrogacy some states allow surrogacy
but don't allow it to be compensated and
the same thing with egg donation in
sperm donation there's sort of different
regulations around who around how these
technologies work depending on what
state you're in in our country and so
that produces a situation that is very
difficult to to keep track of and it
actually is in pretty stark contrast to
many European countries where there is
far more regulation around donation and
anonymity and regulation around
compensation so we in the United States
have very few regulations compared to
most other industrialized countries
I don't know that I would necessarily be
in favor of more regulation I think that
you know recently there have been
stories in the news of a sperm donor
with a hundred and fifty children or
some of these these court cases around
surrogacy that I've talked about and
every time one of these sort of
scandalous stories about the fertility
industry comes out the first call that
you see in the newspapers is for more
regulation more regulation and I think
that's understandable but I would take a
step back and say well first of all we
actually need more information about how
the fertility industry works at this
point there is no national body that
collects statistics about how many egg
donors and sperm donors there are in the
United States about how often they
donate about how many children are born
from egg or sperm donations about what
happens to those children so we just
have just an absolute dearth of
information about how the industry
actually works so I would argue that
before we can regulate we have to know
what's going on and so my call would
actually be for more more data more
information about how it works